the patriots come to town cam newton
faces patrick mahomes for the first time
in their respective careers and earlier
today bill belichick coach of the
patriots continuing to do what he didn't
do all that often with his quarterback
of 20 years publicly he prays on cam
newton
cam ken does a great job of
connecting with everybody
whether it's his teammates his receivers
guys on defense you know other people in
the organization um
you know again i think the
the captain voting not that that's the
ultimate um
you know that's the the final you know
determination of leadership but
i think the fact that he has been here a
pretty short amount of time and earned
that type of
uh respect and support from his
teammates is is pretty impressive um so
but you know i think it's across the
board it's the offensive line it's the
receivers it's all the offensive players
and coaches and
um you know it extends into other areas
as well and special teams and defense
and other people in the organization i
think that we've all seen that and
it's impressive it's impressive and he's
you know he's here a lot
um he's in the building and he's you
know
he's he's visible he's in sight and it's
connecting with people on a
you know
as much as anybody as much as any player
he's in a building more than any player
on the team but you know he spends a lot
of time you know talking and connecting
and
and building relationships with those
people and i mean he has tremendous
leadership so it's very impressive
great stuff from bill belichick about
his quarterback cam newton and i need to
say one thing before we break down the
merits and i at the risk of angering
some who think we have far more
important things to worry about in this
world than what bill belichick wears to
a press conference can we please pull up
a still frame because i have many
questions well i have one specific
question what can we get that can we get
that place what in the hell
was going on with the thing that he was
wearing over the t-shirt and thank god
he wore the t-shirt thank god he had a
t-shirt on
under this thing that it looks like rats
nod away at the neck what is that that's
not a fashion statement what is that i i
i don't get it i don't understand it is
there a message here is there a deeper
meaning how in the world does a guy
who's making upwards of 20 million
dollars per year put that on
and say
i'm good i'm ready let's go i don't get
it shereen can you help me understand it
i couldn't take my eyes off of it and i
was going to go there if you didn't go
there because i think subway needs a new
commercial with cutting cutting off the
collar of shirts instead of just cutting
off the sleeves of shirts i have never
seen him wear something like that before
no hoodie and we can't tell if the
sleeves are cut off or not but that's
really a bad look
i don't know what that is i don't know
what the point is i don't know if there
was supposed to be something else on top
of it i just look to the extent that
bill belichick is trying to confuse and
confound anyone who would be paying
attention to his press conferences
mission accomplished bill because i
don't know what the hell that was but i
do know what the contents were high
praise for cam newton and
they they got one of the greatest steals
of all time shireen didn't they and they
played it the right way they waited
until he was on the market for nearly
three months
no one else had any idea that they
wanted him no one else was competing for
his services they swoop in they get a
deal that pays a maximum of seven and a
half million dollars basically if he's
the regular season and super bowl mvp
and he's combining great performance on
the field with great leadership off the
field and i remember someone telling me
before the first game of the regular
season no one can replace tom brady in
this organization but
cam newton may be the closest thing that
we ever find to it and he fell right
into their laps right after tom brady
left
boy is he going to get a lot of money in
the off season and and if he makes all
of his money this season mike we know
that the patriots have had another
incredible season and
have just
cemented their legacy if it's not
already cemented and it is but just to
do it with another quarterback would be
incredible but they're playing like that
they're really good and i think the most
impressive thing to me is is how they've
designed their offense every week to
match what the opponent does week one it
was a read option heavy offense week two
was a lot of downfield passing week
three it was more traditional rushing
attack every week it's been something
different and josh mcdaniels has done a
great job i think he's a candidate right
now after three weeks for
assistant coach of the year because it's
been outstanding with what he's done
with cam newton now we know the big
question is
can cam stay healthy and i'm not jinxing
him i'm just saying based on the last
two years that's going to be the key
thing going forward for cam newton and
this offense
well if he gets injured a lot of us will
be blamed for jinxing him because that's
been the question that keeps coming up
over and over again that offense they're
running as andy reid pointed out earlier
this week it's based on what josh
mcdaniels concocted in denver for tim
tebow if it's blocked properly the
quarterback isn't at the same kind of
risk that they otherwise would be and
when you go back and watch some of these
games the runs most of them for cam
newton he's not taking big hits and it's
hard to give the guy big hits because
he's so large but this weekend the
challenge is going to be
can he throw if that's what they're
giving him if he can't run the ball can
he get the ball down the field can he do
more than lamar jackson did throwing the
ball against the kansas city defense and
one bit of good news for the patriots
potentially chris jones star defensive
tackle has a groin injury questionable
for the game even if he plays it sounds
like there's going to be some sort of a
limitation so maybe the defense not as
potent on sunday as it was on monday
night sheree
yeah that is good news the patriots if
that happens and he's certainly not
going to be 100 and we saw him wreck
havoc
uh and he didn't even play the entire
game on monday night against the the
ravens he went out with that groin
injury and was gimpy and still forced
two fumbles and two sacks and and was
incredible all over the field and he was
my defensive player of the week for what
he and that chief's defense did and they
just bottled up lamar jackson and they
looked to do the same against cam newton
but you know you got a mastermind on the
other side who's going to look at what
happened monday night and try to figure
out how to
take that kansas city defense and tear
it apart and he's done it to many
defenses over the years
i just wish this game was being played
later in the year because i feel like
the patriots are going to be a lot
better come november and december than
they are now just like the seahawks game
and
even though the patriots of the team i
picked to make it out of the afc to the
super bowl i expect them to lose on
sunday and maybe they'll make it close
maybe it'll be like the seahawks game
where they're down 10 or more points and
they rally late and i think we need to
see cam newton in a setting like that
where things maybe aren't going as well
as expected and and he wills his his way
back into it kind of like they almost
did in seattle they almost came back and
won the game so it's going to be a tough
challenge chiefs are doing whatever they
want to do offensively the question is
can you do enough offensively to
outscore the kansas city chiefs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports